FOXNewsPodcast.com AND THAT’S
AVAILABLE UNTIL JULY 23.
HAVE A GREAT NIGHT.
HE’S A GOOD MUSICAL >> Tucker:
GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
THE PRESIDENT ANNOUNCED THIS
AFTERNOON THAT THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY HAS CANCELED ITS
TRADITIONAL NOMINATING
CONVENTION IN FLORIDA NEXT
MONTH.
THE REASON?
CORONAVIRUS.
>> President Trump: THIS
AFTERNOON MY POLITICAL TEAM CAME
TO ME AND LAID OUT OUR PLANS FOR
THEIR CONVENTION IN
JACKSONVILLE, FLORIDA.
IT’S A PLACE I LOVE AND ALL OF
THE STATE BUT I LOOKED AT MY
TEAM AND I SAID, THE TIMING FOR
THIS EVENT IS NOT RIGHT, IT’S
JUST NOT RIGHT WITH WHAT
HAPPENED.
TO HAVE THE BIG CONVENTION IS TO
HAVE THE RIGHT TIME.
>> Tucker: THAT NEWS WILL
INCONVENIENCE PEOPLE, BUT IN THE
END IT’S HARD TO BELIEVE THAT
CANCELING A POLITICAL CONVENTION
WILL AFFECT THE OUTCOME
ULTIMATELY OF THIS YEAR’S
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
YET IT’S VERY LIKELY THAT THE
CORONAVIRUS LOCKDOWN IT
THEMSELVES WILL AFFECT THE
OUTCOME.
IS YOUR COUNTRY ON THE RIGHT
TRACK OR THE WRONG TRACK?
IN A REELECTION CAMPAIGN
ESPECIALLY THAT IS ALWAYS THE
QUESTION AND EVERY POLITICAL
CONSULTANT IN AMERICA KNOWS THAT
THAT.
THE BITING CAMPAIGN, AND THE
PRESIDENTIAL IS HERE.
IN SOME PLACES OF EARLY VOTING
BEGINS IN JUST A MONTH.
THE RESULT OF THAT VOTING WILL
DEFINE THE COUNTRY’S FUTURE.
IF THE DEMOCRATS TAKE THE SENATE
AT THE WHITE HOUSE, AND THEY
COULD DO, YOU WILL NOT RECOGNIZE
AMERICA A YEAR FROM NOW.
THINK ABOUT HOW MUCH HAS CHANGED
OVER THE PAST SIX MONTHS.
IMAGINE WHAT WOULD HAVE HAPPENED
IF THERE HAD BEEN NO MEANINGFUL
OPPOSITION TO THE MOB, IF
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ HAD
BEEN ABLE TO IMPOSE HER PLANS
WITHOUT ANY RESTRAINT.
THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT THEY INTENT
TO DO.
THEY AREN’T HIDING IT.
>> IF MITCH McCONNELL DOES
WHAT HE DID TO PRESIDENT OBAMA
THEN WE SHOULD GET RID OF THE
FILIBUSTER.
>> RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOUR
GOVERNMENT PLAN WOULD PROVIDE
COVERAGE FOR UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> THAT IS WHY WE WILL IMPLEMENT
LEGISLATION BASED ON THE
PRINCIPLES OF THE GREEN NEW
DEAL.
>> ARE YOU PROPOSING TAKING AWAY
THEIR GUNS AND HOW WOULD THIS
WORK?
>> I AM, IF IT’S A WEAPON THAT
WAS DESIGNED TO KILL PEOPLE ON A
BATTLEFIELD.
>> YES, WE WILL TAKE YOUR AR-15
INCHER AK-47.
>> IT’S FUNNY, PEOPLE ASK ME
WHAT THE WORLD FOR DEFUND THE
POLICE LOOKS LIKE.
>> THEY ARE NOT MODERATES AND
THIS IS NOT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
THAT YOU REMEMBER.
DON’T BE LIBERALS WITH FLACCID
IDEAS THAT YOU PROBABLY HAD
CONTEMPT FOR BUT IN THE END
COULD LIVE WITH.
NO, THESE ARE RADICALS AND THEY
DESPISE THE COUNTRY THEY SEEK TO
GOVERN.
THEY CLAIM TO REMAKE IT
COMPLETELY.
THESE PEOPLE WANT POWER WITH AN
INTENSITY THAT YOU AS A NORMAL
WELL-ADJUSTED PERSON CANNOT EVEN
BEGIN TO UNDERSTAND.
THEY WILL DO ANYTHING FOR
CONTROL.
SO THE QUESTION IS, WHAT ARE
THEY DOING TO WIN?
THEY ARE WORKING THE RIGHT
TRACK/WRONG TRACK NUMBERS.
DEMOCRATS UNDERSTAND THAT THE
UNHAPPIER AMERICANS BECOME, THE
MORE LIKELY THEY ARE TO WIN.
UNHAPPY PEOPLE WANT CHANGE, IT’S
NOT COMPLICATED.
SO EVERY OMINOUS HEADLINE ABOUT
THE STATE OF THE COUNTRY MAKES
IT MORE LIKELY THAT DONALD TRUMP
WILL LOSE HIS JOB.
THE MORE THE PEOPLE SUFFER, THE
GREATER JOE BIDEN’S ADVANTAGE.
DEMOCRATS HAVE A STRONG
INCENTIVE TO THEREFORE INFLICT
AS MUCH PAIN AS THEY CAN AND
THAT’S WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
ON MARCH 1ST NEW YORK STATE
CONFIRMED ITS FIRST CASE OF THE
CORONAVIRUS.
AT THE TIME YOU MAY NOT
REMEMBER, THE MEDIA WAS STILL
ATTACKING THE PRESIDENT FOR
TAKING THE CORONAVIRUS TOO
SERIOUSLY.
THEY SAID THE TRAVEL BAN ON
CHINA WAS HYSTERICAL IN THE
XENOPHOBIC.
TWO DAYS LATER CITING THE
PANDEMIC, THE OHIO
GOVERNOR MIKE DeWINE BAND
SPECTATORS FROM A SPORTING EVENT
ON "THE WASHINGTON POST" SCOFFED
AT HIM.
THE PAPER CALLED HIS
RESTRICTIONS "RADICAL."
ON THAT DAY, MARCH 3RD, MORE
THAN 40% OF THE COUNTRY WAS
HEADED AND AT THE NUMBER WAS WAY
TOO HIGH.
THEN WITHIN A WEEK HIGHER
EDUCATION STARTED TO SHUT DOWN
AT A LIFE STARTED TO CHANGE FOR
MANY PEOPLE.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF IDLE
COLLEGE AGED KIDS RETURN HOME.
STORES BEGAN TO EMPTY, HAND
SANITIZERS AND CLEANING SUPPLIES
DISAPPEARED.
ON MARCH 12TH THE HOCKEY LEAGUE
CANCELED AT SEASON AND MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL FOLLOWED SUIT.
IT’S STILL 40%, AND THAT WAS BAD
NEWS FOR THE JOE BIDEN CAMPAIGN.
THE CDC RECOMMENDED CANCELING
ALL PUBLIC EVENTS ARE MORE THAN
50 PEOPLE PRESENT.
PUBLIC SCHOOLS CLOSED AND SO DID
BARS, RESTAURANTS, GYMS AND
CHURCHES.
CRITICALLY MILLIONS LOST THEIR
JOBS AND BUSINESSES WERE
SHUTTERED AND THEN THE
EMPLOYMENT RATE ROSE TO THE
HIGHEST LEVEL IN NEARLY A
CENTURY.
AT THE TIME THEY TOLD US THAT
MASS QUARANTINES WERE ESSENTIAL.
THEY WERE SAVING LIVES WITH OUR
SUFFERING AND MOST PEOPLE WANTED
TO BELIEVE THAT BECAUSE MOST
AMERICANS ARE DECENT PEOPLE.
SCIENCE HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
THIS.
STUDIES AROUND THE WORLD SHOWED
THAT BEING OUTSIDE WAS FAR SAFER
THAN STAYING AT HOME.
THAT WAS CONCLUSIVE.
IN MICHIGAN, WHICH IS NOT
COINCIDENTALLY A SWING STATE,
DEMOCRATS BANNED CITIZENS FROM
VISITING THEIR OWN WEEKEND HOMES
OR USING OUTBOARD MOTORS.
AFTER A WHILE THE AUTHORITIES
ISSUING THESE ORDERS AND ANTHONY
FAUCI FOR A LONG TIME, IT SEEMS
LIKE A SERIOUS MAN OF SCIENCE
ANNOUNCED IT WAS DANGEROUS TO
SHAKE HANDS WITH PEOPLE YOU LOVE
BUT IT WAS FINE TO HAVE SACKS
WITH STRANGERS ONLINE.
THEY WERE REVEALED TO BE
CAPRICIOUS.
ABOVE ALL THOUGH, AND THIS WAS
THE POINT, THEY MADE AMERICANS
MISERABLE.
PRESCRIPTIONS FOR
ANTIDEPRESSANTS ROSE 21% IN A
SINGLE MONTH.
BY THE END OF APRIL THE RIGHT
ATTRACT/WRONG TRACK NUMBERS
INVERTED.
AND YET FOR THE PEOPLE PUSHING
JOE BIDEN FOR PRESIDENT, THAT
NUMBER WAS STILL TOO HIGH SO WE
HAD RIOTS.
AS THE ENTIRE COUNTRY WATCHED IN
REAL TIME, MOB SALUTED AND
BURNED AT THE POLICE STATION AND
MINNEAPOLIS.
WE SAW PEOPLE DRAGGED FROM THEIR
STORES AND BEATEN ON CAMERA,
SOME WERE KILLED.
MOST PEOPLE WATCHING THIS WERE
HORRIFIED BY PROFESSIONAL
DEMOCRATS WERE THRILLED.
THEY SLASHED POLICE BUDGETS TO
ENSURE IT WOULD CONTINUE AND IT
DID.
CRIME RATES SOARED AND THE
CRACKDOWN ON NORMAL PEOPLE
ACCELERATED.
YOUR KIDS WERE NOT ALLOWED TO
HAVE GRADUATION CEREMONIES OR
GET MARRIED, BUT HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CONFIRMED JOE BIDEN
VOTERS WERE ALLOWED TO FLOOD THE
STREETS AND BREAK THINGS.
THEN MIDSUMMER CAME.
WITH THE ELECTION JUST MONTHS
AWAY AT AMERICA’S SUFFERING HAD
TO BE INTENSIFIED.
SO SCHOOLS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
ANNOUNCED THEY WOULD STAY CLOSED
IN THE FALL.
NO ONE BOTHERED TO EXPLAIN THE
SCIENCE BEHIND US BECAUSE THERE
WASN’T ANY.
SCHOOLCHILDREN REMAIN NEARLY
IMMUNE TO THE FATAL EFFECTS OF
CORONAVIRUS AND TO THIS DAY
THERE WAS NOT A SINGLE REPORTED
CASE IN THE ENTIRE WORLD OF A
STUDENT PASSING COVID-19 TO A
TEACHER, NOT ONE CASE.
BUT SCHOOL SHUT DOWN ANYWAY.
DESPERATE PARENTS WONDERED WHAT
THEY WOULD DO WITH THEIR KIDS IN
SEPTEMBER.
GOOD LUCK THEY WERE TOLD, FIGURE
SOMETHING OUT.
RESIDENTS OF WASHINGTON, D.C.,
WERE TOLD THEY WOULD BE REQUIRED
BY LAW TO WEAR MASKS EVERYWHERE
THEY WENT FOR THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE, AND YET, THE PEOPLE WHO
MADE THAT LAW EXEMPTED
THEMSELVES FROM IT.
THEY ALREADY KNOW THEY ARE
VOTING FOR JOE BIDEN.
EVERYONE ELSE IN THE COUNTRY
BECAME DRAMATICALLY UNHAPPIER.
NEARLY THREE QUARTERS OF
AMERICANS NOW SAY THE COUNTRY
HAS BECOME A MUCH WORSE PLACE
THAN IT WAS.
DOCTORS HAVE PRESCRIBED IS SO
MUCH ZOLOFT, THE ANTIDEPRESSANT,
IT’S NOT ON THE FEDERAL DRUG
SHORTAGE LIST.
IN FACT IT’S LIKELY AMERICANS
HAVE NEVER IN HISTORY OF THIS
COUNTRY BEEN AS UNHAPPY AS THEY
HAVE RIGHT RIGHT NOW.
IT’S A TRAGEDY, BUT FOR
DEMOCRATS IT IS A WIN.
ACCORDING TO POLLS, REPUBLICANS
ME NOW LOSE ONE SAFE SENATE